welcome everyone to the data science
hangout
and i know
most people who are on today they've
you've been here before so you kind of
know the drill
but for anyone who's new today
this is an open space for current and
aspiring data science leaders to connect
and just chat about some of the more
human-centric questions around data
science leadership
but also to focus on questions that are
most important to you all so there's
three ways that you can ask questions
you could just jump in live
put questions in the chat
or we also do have a slido link where
you can ask anonymous questions too
and rob will share that link in the chat
in just a moment here
but just a quick note that the session
will be
recorded and shared up to youtube
so just want to make you aware of that
if you're jumping in live
but again feel free to ask questions
anonymously too
i'm so happy to be joined by my co-host
for today zach garland manager of
econometrics and data science at
mastercard
and zach i'd love to just have you
introduce yourself and maybe share a bit
about the work that you're doing on your
team today
yeah no absolutely um hi everyone
my name is zach garland
um i'm part of the economics institute
of mastercard
and i i think
the easiest way to kind of summarize
what we do
we like building cool [ __ ]
um and all you know i'll try to to not
cuss but i wanted to make this feel very
open um i'm obviously not in a suit or
you know anything special i'm kind of in
you know what i'm in every day
um and so yeah it you know open
questions feel free to ask anything um
yeah
excited to be here
awesome so while we're waiting for a few
questions to come in as well
zach i think one of the things that was
really interesting to me chatting with
you this week is
um
really about the ways that you go you
make people interested in data and then
the work that you're doing on your team
i think it'd be cool to just maybe share
a few examples of some of the stuff that
you're working on
yeah no absolutely
um
so
i guess there's there's a lot of broad
things that data science covers
um i think that we try to figure out how
to approach it really holistically
um you know from the point that you pull
the data
to transforming the data or visualizing
it and you know i guess some simple
plots and then how does that eventually
make its way to either a product or
um an output like a report and so you
know one of the ways that we're
constantly communicating is is really a
public report
um and then we have kind of our client
presentations or
um i guess you could say stakeholder
presentations where that's really the
summarized view
um and in general i mean i think that we
always try to summarize you know big
topics
um in a way that everyone can consume
and that's my dog winston by the way um
for anyone that was curious
i love the dog running up in the
background yeah no he's he's the he's
the day one homie but
um
yeah and and you know i think that we we
try to find ways to explain it to
a sixth grader right like i think
within data science you can get very
very in the weeds and it's all super
exciting for people that understand it
but for someone that's not familiar with
data science or how to interpret data
you almost have to find a way to really
explain it or
find a way to summarize your ideas and
so i think that that's always been kind
of a driving factor for us
and even you know we have
we have this framework where
it's
what am i looking at
and why does it matter
and it's it's a very you know two very
simple questions
but i think it you know
it gets to the heart of what you're
trying to do which is you know
show something and then why does that
matter um and so yeah that that's kind
of a side comment but
awesome and kind of going on on that
path as well i see kevin you just asked
a question
um
around the late what's your latest
fun project that you've worked on
yeah so um
i would say that it's
it was a very fun project but it was
very very um work intensive so we're
we're coming out with a small business
report and
the fun thing at least from my
perspective i like developing um i like
code
and
i've been
learning javascript um trying to find
more ways to use it and so from my
perspective the most exciting or fun
thing was i finally found a way to have
um
basically a static rendered or markdown
map
show all of these individual city level
leaflet maps um and so i'm talking in r
but um i think that's probably
acceptable here but um it was super fun
for me to figure that out and find a way
to make it work
um and
yeah i think it's it's a very visually
appealing report and so
i think we're releasing it uh next
tuesday and i i can send out a link um
to that but um there is just a general
you know mastercard
services.com
economics institute um where you can
find like most of our public reports and
so that's that's a really good place to
at least kind of see what's accessible
or out in the public you know view
and then outside of that you know i
would say that we're constantly trying
to focus on the business or
trying to understand where does this fit
in the big picture um how do we provide
value to
our clients how do we provide value to
our stakeholders um and so those are
always you know really exciting
those are more thought processes or how
do we
you know think about this
how do we think about it differently
what's bad what's good you know so on
and so forth so
yeah
one question that i had for you and
if anybody else has other questions you
want to ask live feel free to jump in
uh
but i know mastercard being such a huge
company i was curious how you go about
like showing the value of open source
and explaining
to
maybe other stakeholders um the
importance of open source
yeah no absolutely
um
so i think
when i think about open source i mean
i'm in love with open source um
i think there's a lot of value in
sharing code and using code debugging
code
um and having that all available and so
i mean one of the reasons why i'm such a
our studio supporter advocate is
all of the packages
were built for some reason and they all
more or less speak together um they talk
to each other they have the ability to
integrate functions with you know one
another and i think when you when you
start to
scratch um which is really what you know
i joined shortly after the group was
started and
there wasn't you know any paid pathway
or any you know determined this is what
we have to do
and so when you start from scratch like
that it offers the ability to
really design
a full framework or a entire system or
an entire portal
um however you want to kind of describe
it but
it it makes it interesting when you
start doing that to see how much you're
leveraging open source because
it's probably a lot um and that's that's
always been kind of my view that
many companies are seeing the end result
of open source but i think the
conversation
really has started to turn more towards
you know how do we start to be an active
member
how do we start to think about what we
need to keep
very secure and
um i guess behind
some form of authentication
and then how do we also start to
generate new ideas with open source or
how do we start to partner with them to
take on a big project
or
if we have an idea you know how do we
start to think about what can be open
source versus what couldn't be um and i
think the easiest like intro to that is
talking through inner source so how do
we share within the company first um how
do we start to approach you know
broad frameworks or
you know building out all of these
different components and so i think
the inner source conversation is is an
easier one to approach or get into
but i think eventually that that really
transitions into how do we talk about
open source how do we you know view open
source
um and how do we really collaborate and
contribute
that's one of the first times i myself
have heard the like inner inner source
and open source conversation and was
just curious if others from the group as
well
have talked about it that way or thought
about it that way with leadership
we've talked about it and
implemented certain things but i like
having the term that specifically
identifies what you're saying i'm going
to totally take your term
sure for what it's worth it's not my
term i don't remember where i read it
but i was like yes that's exactly like
um
yeah
i
i'm trying to thank you for sharing it
of course yeah
i like that
um daniel i see that you asked a
question in the chat and i wanted to
pass the mic over to you to have you ask
that live
sure sure um so basically my question
was just if you could talk a little bit
about kind of like the idea generation
and idea refinement process to kind of
get to things that you actually want
your team to work on in the sense that
like i think a common
uh
dilemma is that like the
i just use business it's kind of like
the non-tech folks but like the business
folks kind of know a lot about their
individual problem areas but don't know
about the tech side and the tech side
obviously knows sex side but at the
business side and so you can get ideas
from
either or
uh but like how you go about kind of
getting this
from the larger number of like potential
projects
to the ones that like you actually have
your team working on
yeah no i i think that that's a great
question um
i would say that our team is
constantly
generating ideas and so
i would say that we have a very
almost open board when it comes to
new ideas or doing new things
and i think we're very quick to
drop something that you know we thought
was interesting but then
turns out it would take too much or the
data would be too hard to pull or
there's some you know something that
causes us to kind of change paths and
then when we find something that's
that's really good i would say that we
invest in it and we double down on it
and i i like that approach because
it's it's a it's almost an open
you know collaboration between teams
like how do we come up with the best
ideas how do we move on from bad ideas
quickly and then how do we really hone
in on what's good um and so i think it
works well you know the the hard part
about it is sometimes managing
a lot of things going on at once um i
think for anyone that codes or is in
data science they know how
intense some of the projects can get and
so i think managing expectations and
trying to communicate you know
requirements or needs is super important
um but generally you know if if you have
good ideas or you can constantly come up
with new ones and and find a way to
really communicate them
um it makes for a fun environment
can i just ask one quick follow-up to
that uh based on part of what you were
what you were saying uh
like i like the idea of kind of being
able to pivot quickly
uh in
doubling down on kind of like the the
uh
the things that are worth doubling down
on do you ever get pushed back when
you're dropping some of the stuff that
is no longer seen as important and kind
of like how do you deal with that
yeah um
i mean there's there's always going to
be pushback from
some area right where
there's so many people to please and
[Music]
there's so much
that that you know is in the realm of
possibilities or opportunities
and
you know i think managing expectations
and really just trying to communicate is
super super important
um and you know i think that that's
that's where sometimes you get into
trouble is not communicating needs or um
not you know finding a way to really
communicate so that someone else has
understanding
um and
yeah so i i mean
the the short answer is
there's no perfect solution
and there's always going to be someone
that that wants to go one way and you
want the other but the more that you can
kind of be confident in what you're
you're
planning to do or want to do and then
really just doing it
it makes it a lot easier to kind of come
back with well we didn't we didn't get
this done but here's what we got done
um and you know things like that are
helpful
do you have any tips on communicating
those expectations
i almost want to say i'll let you know
when i find them but um
i i would say
you know really just going back to kind
of the
how do we explain this to someone that
doesn't understand it
and
the best way to do that in my opinion is
kind of treat it like you're explaining
it to a six-year-old
how do you explain the big picture
what's the goal
why does it matter
[Music]
what does it require
and not getting too in the weeds of
of the details i guess not i think
any time that you approach data science
it you're always going to find people
that really don't understand it or
don't understand what's involved with
the code or how it needs to scale
and so the more that you can kind of
bring it to
a mutual understanding or common ground
that makes it easier but it's certainly
a topic that i think
over time will get better
i think data fluency is something that
will improve in the future
i think more more and more people will
code
um i would love to see it um i guess
from my perspective i'm a self-taught uh
coder and so i think there's so much
great material out in open source
whether that's books or videos webinars
um packages
all of it really comes together to
create a more open environment where
that understanding starts to bridge
but i think we're kind of early in the
game like i think that
data science is relatively new even
though it's super super old
but the concept of you know how much
data is becoming available and how much
data
is being generated really opens up that
door for for people to start having that
conversation
thank you
tatiana i see you asked a question in
the chat around
a framework
would you want to introduce yourself and
jump in and ask that question
sure well first of all thank you so much
for organizing this is this is great uh
thanks zachary for sharing your
knowledge so generously this appreciated
i
i got some online certifications in data
science obviously i'm not a super big
expert in a subject and i'm willing to
learn i'm currently working as a
business intelligence analyst and i have
a question about frameworks that you use
when approaching a new topic from how
you manage expectations to how you
decide which project in your words is
good or bad do you have specific apis
that you go
to to measure your new project against
do you have specific steps that you go
from um
i don't know from uh deciding on whether
or not to take it on to
um
measuring which model it's best to use
to maybe setting adoption targets and
making sure that the data is validated
and the users are using it so any tips
that you can give regarding that
yeah no i i think that that's a great
question um
and so
i guess the the way that i've approached
projects has always been and and not
always um
i wish that i had approached projects
you know always this way but i always
start with a package um and the first
package that i started at the economics
institute was this package called ei
tools
and it's
it's a conglomerate of many things in
the tidy verse or and use this for
anyone that's familiar with that but i
always start with a package so anytime i
have a new idea i build out you know a
simple package and then store it you
know everything that's related to that
inside of that package
and i think what that offers the
opportunity to do is to really have
organization around all the things going
on so
if an idea gets dropped it's not a big
deal it's still there um
but at least it's it's getting to the
right framework or
starting to be in the right form before
you really pursue something and so i
guess by way of example when i was
getting started
um i built out this this big application
and it had a ton of functionality
um and it was more or less just me
learning um
but i didn't build it in a package you
know files were were
hard referenced and
there was just a million things that you
know could have been improved if i had
come up with kind of that that initial
package structure
um and so i think the more that you kind
of um
dive into projects
you start to kind of find a flow and i
think the package structure really works
well for me
um and i i would say it's it's not an
easy thing to get through um
none of it's easy and it all takes a lot
of time and
and learning you know trying failing um
all things that i've i've done and so
um yeah i would say as long as you have
kind of a positive mindset about it and
try to to get things organized um the
better off you'll be
and then in terms of you know
um model performance and how to think
about all that
i think it's such a big topic that
there's no perfect answer um
i think the more that you can focus on
kind of the end output for
what the value is of what you're trying
to do
the better and then the the rest of it
is kind of just details
thank you zach
i see there's a lot of chat uh
conversation going on in the chat around
a specific question too so hugh i'd love
to have you ask your questions in life
sure um and thank you uh septori and i'm
bruno those are really good thoughts uh
things i hadn't considered before um
uh i'm also mostly self-taught it's nice
to hear that
i'm not alone um but one of the things
that i know i personally struggle with
is every time i pick up a new
resource or uh any kind of training i'm
i'm finding
things that i feel like i should have
known early on or you know blind spots
in my knowledge do you have any
strategies for
kind of proactively seeking those out
yeah so
um
i you know i think it's it's a very
individual question where
i think there's plenty of ways that
people can learn um for me i love books
um and i have too many that i haven't
read
um too many that i buy and i'm like i'm
gonna read and then i just don't um but
what i like about books is
if you start from the very top and you
finish it
you have so much knowledge that that
author had um and so a great example is
just the data science for our book
um
it took me a long time to really get
through the entire book go through all
the exercises and to really understand
the concepts
um but once i felt like i had really
mastered all the concepts or really read
through all the chapters
i felt like i had almost a framework um
and same thing with the r packages book
or
you know the mastering shiny book um and
there's there's actually this book
that's called the big book of r
um and it's basically just links to
books on different topics or different
ideas
different approaches or things that you
could learn and so i always think that
that's a really great reference
videos are super helpful at least for me
but i mean anything you know training
courses um
or
you know in-person meetups or and i know
we're we're kind of still on covet so
maybe not in-person meetups but um
things like this you know how do you
think about new ideas or get
um get someone else to share ideas on
code or data science modeling you know
all of these different things that that
are available so
yeah i i would say that um the the fear
of not knowing what you should have
known that that's always present like i
know that there's a million things i
don't know
um but i do know that there's ways to
find it um or to learn it and so as long
as you kind of have a learning mindset
then
you know it's always the the best place
to start
thank you i appreciate that
so yeah your stack of unread books
sounds like you're describing my
nightstand
i have a coffee table and i think
sometimes um when when people come over
and you know they'll see it like right
now uh the book that i haven't gotten
all the way through would love to is
this book called full stack um d3 and
it's this gorgeous book um gorgeous
cover
and it's just this massive textbook and
i think people always come in and
they're like you're not reading this and
i'm like yeah no i'm not like
but i'm trying to you know
i'm trying to so
the question is are your is your
nightstand and coffee table made of
these books or the books
i um
i do like woodworking so i i actually
built like my record soon but um haven't
made anything out of books um that's a
that's a new idea so
maybe i'll have to think about that
i see there's a few helpful books that
people are sharing in the chat window as
well so feel free to share any others
there or anyone listening in too
there's a few anonymous questions coming
in too so i want to make sure i ask a
few of those
um and the first one was how do you
communicate your results do you use the
open source solution enterprise cloud or
something else
yeah so
i think that that's a great
a great question
um
so i think when you're developing on
your own
you have open source to leverage and
really
constantly evolving technology
and i think when you're in a company the
the thing that i didn't understand
before was really
you know
there are predetermined systems or
predetermined um
technology solutions
that you kind of have to start with
where you know even if there's a better
solution out there um what's available
is kind of what you get and so i think
there's there's almost this balance
between
what do we have access to today and what
do we really want to have access to
tomorrow
um you know and how do we start to
communicate
where these different technologies come
into place or what that would enable
um you to do
and i think you know developing on your
own i i would always urge people to to
constantly push new technologies and to
find ways to to really utilize them um
and i actually i saw this pdf where it
went over the data landscape or
um all of the different technologies
that are going on in the world and
there's so much um and so i think
opportunity is there
and you just have to find out how do we
kind of
hand pick um what's really going to work
for our group or for the company um and
then how do we start to kind of pursue
it um yeah
hopefully that helps
following up on that question i guess if
you
like find a technology that you want to
pursue
what does that process look like for you
or what tips you have for someone who's
trying to do that
yeah absolutely so i think that really
gets to
um
communicating with stakeholders right so
finding some way to
use what you have access to today to
provide value
and then coming back and saying i know
that you love this but here's what we
could do with this
and i think it's really you know finding
ways to
produce something that people really
understand and
view as valuable
and then showing them how they that new
technologies or additional systems could
really enhance that or improve it scale
it
and just showing them kind of what that
next step might look like
but really just opening up the
conversation you know finding ways to
ask questions or to say
here's something i think would be super
valuable how should we approach that um
because i think that that's also
something that
people should be comfortable with is
you're not always going to know how to
do something like that or how to really
start asking those questions and so i
think
you know just starting with hey here's
something i'm thinking through
here's why i think that might be
valuable you know how should we think
about that or how could we approach that
is always super super helpful
cool thank you
bruno i see you had asked a question
earlier around the data that zach works
with would you want to
ask that question live
yeah sure all right thanks for me
i think you just muted yourself on
accident
sorry there you go hi
how are you doing
uh thanks for uh doing this uh i was
just wondering at the mastercard scale
uh like with many data scientists how do
you uh
how do you process everything you can
use
like you have access to so much data
like what what resources do you use what
challenge do you face
uh processing all that information
yeah so
you know i think that um
that's a great question
um when it comes to data and even just
our group
so our group is made up of economists
and data scientists
and so even the economists look at as
much data as they possibly can
we were we were reviewing with a vendor
you know
how many different series or how many
different things we look at over a given
year and it's it's a lot um so i think
the more that you can be curious about
what's available or how do we find ways
to really leverage that or view it
visualize it model it um
the better off you'll be but there's
there's certainly you know plenty of
challenges along the way to actually
getting
data then going through a process of
modeling or
coming up with summary statistics and
then really what's the end output how do
we visualize that how do we communicate
it to others
and so i think the more that you you
constantly stay curious the better off
you are but there's there's certainly um
plenty of challenges that come up along
the way so
maybe a bit related
to this there was an anonymous question
that asked have you had any issues with
using large data sets in r um and do you
have any favorite packages to deal with
that
yeah so um you know i think
i think when it comes to that
or works for just about anything at
least from what i've found
um there's certainly times where you're
trying to do too much with it and it
might be slow
but generally speaking
you could load in
massive files and
manipulate all of it and then output it
to some small table
i think that sql is kind of the the
natural progression to larger and larger
data um that could be you know a million
different things or you could view that
in a million different ways but
um finding some way to store the data
and then to
pull some level of calculation
um without pulling the full thing
that's kind of the
the best solution so db player um is
kind of the
um the go to at least for me i i like
writing you know and are more than i
like writing sql um even though i do
totally value sql um and i think it's a
valuable skill um
i you know i just love tidy verse and
our packages
thank you so um saul i see you just
asked a question around
metrics for success do you want to add a
little bit of context there
i can just ask
the question is what are metrics that
mastercard uses to measure success or
impact
i think that's a that's a great question
um
it's something that i
i think about often
um i don't know that we have a perfect
solution for that
um
you know i think
if you are generating revenue that's a
super simple way to
you know um kind of measure success
our group currently you know we
we are pursuing um that but
when we got started you know that wasn't
part of what we were doing
um and so i think that that's really
when it starts to get down to
you know how much are we communicating
with clients how much are we
communicating with stakeholders
are we helping them to do their jobs
better or to have a better understanding
of you know data or the macro view
and you know are we really enabling them
to do better and so i think there's
there's plenty of opportunities to kind
of measure or to try and figure out you
know how do we view this as valuable
um but i think um those are kind of the
the two avenues that i would i would
kind of identify
i know one of the examples you had
shared with me was on like travel and
sharing some of those insights
i guess taking that like success
question a bit further like how would
you measure success for that project
yeah so
i i think um
[Music]
very early on we kind of identified core
themes and so
we started with this idea of you know
how do we come up with
you know six or seven themes that
broadly we want to cover or that we want
to have a view on and then how do we
constantly kind of enhance it so
if you were to look at our first
projects or our first you know
dashboards or reports
um we took a view or tried to come up
with a view
um and then we constantly just made it
better so
i don't know that we
we had any measure of of success other
than you know people telling us that
they liked it they valued it you know
they appreciated it um
but
in terms of kind of measuring how
how well we're doing i think it's
certainly an area that
um we could probably do some more
exploring or
thinking through
thank you and i i just shared that link
in the chat if you want to check out
some of that work too
um
i see you asked a question in the chat
can i pass the mic over to you
yeah
um
uh thanks zach for uh for sharing a lot
of these insights um
a lot of the discussion earlier was
around like um
you know kind of uh coding and things of
that nature um how do you
i guess how do you ensure that like your
team
is all kind of using is up to date
basically like you know a lot of people
have different varying levels of skill
with regard to coding or data science
how do you guys kind of make sure that
people are kind of
in sync
yeah no i i think that that's a great
question um
and even for you know data scientists so
like for me i'm very code first um
but a lot of people that we work with or
that are part of our group they work
within tableau
um and so even with tableau you know
the the funny thing about it is there's
and i'm probably kind of getting
sidetracked with a different
maybe i'll mention that after but
um
there's no easy way to make sure that
everyone's on the same page or
has the same code or has the same
understanding of code
what's worked for us is trying to figure
out you know how do we leverage each
other's skills
um
regardless of technologies
and you know a great example is really
tableau so the economist will come up
with these great views or
these great dashboards
and then i can take those and make them
into code or find ways to visualize them
differently
put them into a public report um and so
i think it's it's really just gets down
to communication having an understanding
of skills and then trying you know along
the way to teach each other um and to
learn
um and so i guess the the side uh
portion that i was gonna go off into was
uh under the hood tableau is xml
and so for a coder like i love trying to
parcel of it and trying to understand
like what can i pull out of this or you
know how do i pull this color palette or
um things that are kind of
more nerdy um but it's you know finding
ways to do what you love even though it
might not be with the tool you love or
the technology you know
it's always
kind of the path that i've taken
thanks
expanding on that a bit further i see
there was an anonymous question that
says
what are your thoughts on the no code
movement um in auto ml
yeah so
i i think at the end of the day
there there is value
in
no code and people that don't code
[Music]
i guess from my perspective the reason
why i love coding is
it offers unlimited possibilities so
i think that the main difference for me
has always been
if
this solution doesn't do what i want it
to do
is there any way that i can fix that or
am i kind of um set with what is
available and so for me
i love developing new things or
trying to
generate you know different ways that we
could do something and so that
flexibility for me has always been super
important
um but that being said you know there's
a lot of value like i always go to
tableau as a great example because
dragging and dropping and creating
beautiful visualizations or decks
dashboards is super super valuable um
and
yeah i you know i think both are super
valuable um i've just always been very
code first because i like developing and
um yeah
thanks zach
um one other anonymous question that
came in was how do you balance your
passion and personal interest
and business requirements when it comes
to adopting tools and projects
yeah i you know i think that that's
that's another great question um
it's not always easy um and
you know you you always have to find
ways to
have some level of balance between both
um and a good example is
so when i first started
we had you know we had to really come up
with a business plan and a way to
communicate that
and we wanted to do something kind of
crazy or off the wall and so we used
prezi and it was a great you know it was
a great presentation it was very fun it
was very interactive um and then
eventually i quoted you know an html
presentation but
um i think there's always a balance of
you know
figuring out like what do we really need
and is this the right solution
and then at some point the the hope is
always that you can really really
leverage your skills because you're
starting to produce you know things that
always can answer
questions or can always satisfy some
need
um but that certainly takes time and it
and it certainly doesn't happen you know
overnight but
um the more that you have kind of your
passion and your work the better and i
think the more that you kind of push
that agenda or trying to find ways to do
what you love um
the better off you are
your answer and just mentioning like
presenting the business case was making
me think of something i
had meant to ask earlier as well but
around the economics institute in
general could you explain a bit more
about what that is and how it serves as
an innovation lab
yeah absolutely um
so
we're really a group of you know
economists and data scientists
and our job is to really come up with
great stories and
great insights and you know i think that
we've always taken the view of of trying
to to view things differently
um trying to find the hidden story or
the thing that no one's else you know is
looking at
um
and i think that when we look at the
group as a whole what we're really
talented at is
constantly being in communication with
you know clients stakeholders really
understanding what what challenges or
things that they're going through
and then finding ways to really explain
what's going on how do they think about
that
um how do they view it or come up with
new ways to approach it
um and so i think you know the the group
as a whole is is made up of a lot of
very
curious and
hard-working individuals
um and i think that that that's really
created kind of an environment where
you know we're we're constantly just
trying to find
cool things to to show or communicate
and then you know how do we help people
to do what they do better and so
apologies if i'm pronouncing your name
wrong that you asked a question that
follows this as well
but when you say
like do really cool things or show cool
things with data what are some of the
most interesting insights that you've
gotten so far
from projects you've worked on at
mastercard
yeah um
i i would say it's it for the most part
it's all pretty interesting um sometimes
you know as a data scientist it's hard
to keep up with
what all the different views are or all
of the interesting insights that the
group generates as a whole
um
i would say for me i i've always enjoyed
you know really finding ways to
visualize things
so right now i'm i'm trying to learn d3
because i just find it so cool um
and it's super difficult um and it's not
you know it's not coming easy but
um you know i think even within tableau
you know we have an economist i always
look at her dashboards and i'm like wow
this is like this is so cool
and you know i think it's it's really
just trying to
find things that are interesting and
that you would enjoy or that you find
cool and then you know communicating it
um
but
i guess like
i don't know if there's a specific
example like i i would say the small
business report there's things i find
super cool in that um
there within the travel report you know
there are things that i i found super
cool in that um
but
yeah i don't know it's it's probably uh
an answer of there's so many
uh things that are fun or cool to look
at
it's probably hard to kind of pick one
in terms of the the small business
report what what is that show or
what is that is that a visualization
that you produce
yeah so
you know i think
when
[Music]
when you look at our public reports um
and even just you know i can openly talk
about kind of what's under the hood so
um our public reports for the most part
have always been built with our markdown
um and i think that we try to push it to
the limits of what that that can do
um but generally it's it's a very easy
framework to use
um you can constantly improve it and so
i i think there's always this element of
what it started with was really you know
analytics stuff right where it's very
analytics heavy there's um
there's a very s you know kind of
standard view of color
um where we started to transition to
more elegance and design
um how do we create something that
people are are going to find visually
appealing
um and so i i think that that's that's
probably like my side gig is a you know
design um i enjoy it and
um i think that
you know we we bring in a lot of
visualizations that weren't built with r
um so things like video or pictures or
um you know graphics that are animated
um and so i think it's just finding
cool ways to show what you're trying to
think through or trying to communicate
um
but i certainly kind of love when my
graphics make the end cut as well so
yeah
awesome thank you just scrolling through
to make sure i didn't miss questions
from
earlier
um i see
saul maybe had dropped off but asked the
question earlier on how would you advise
people to learn topics like econometrics
having a limited statistics background
that's a very good question um
[Music]
so
what i've
you know the one thing i realized about
economics is i thought i had some level
of background in it
um and then you meet a bunch of smart
economists and you realize you really
don't know much um and so i think
at the end of the day there's so much
that you can always learn
um econometrics is is not
super straightforward is is probably the
blunt answer
um it's it's complex there's lots of
things that need to be considered or
treated for
um and i think that i'm constantly
learning about it um or trying to
understand it um
but i i don't know that i have any tips
for
here's great references or you know a
lot of the stuff i i've kind of learned
on the job
um and over time and so
yeah
thank you
going back to that last question a
little bit i know you said you like
design and
it's great when sometimes your
visualizations are the ones put out
there
uh how do you kind of test
design and and think about like what
appeals to to people and what's going to
maybe get catch people's attention the
most
yeah
um
i think just trying new things
is is kind of the fun part about design
is
um there's there's always some way that
you could show it differently
and there's always a different color
palette or a different font or
a different size of of your header and
you know i think all of those things
kind of come together um to create an
output and so
the
the easiest way to
um play around with design is just kind
of i i guess like design is mostly at
least for um
you know web frameworks it's just having
fun with you know css and javascript and
kind of just diving in um changing
around you know backgrounds or like we
started with
very very bold and fluorescent colors
and then we realized well maybe not
everyone likes looking at something so
you know intense and you know how do we
make that maybe a bit more
um
easy on the eyes i guess and you know
how do we change a color palette to
really show what we're trying to
visualize
um and so i think all of those things
are super fun to play around with um and
yeah just kind of getting in there and
changing everything
i know you said
well you've said already too but that
brooklyn said you want this to be a
place of innovation
and that there's been reports that were
more of static texts and pdfs which
you're trying to make cooler um i'm just
wondering like is there an example of
a report that you've done that for
internally or
what kinds of reports for those
yeah so
you know i think that um
one of the big things that griff and i
are always on the same page about was
interactivity so how do we increase
someone's ability to really play around
with it or
um you know to really understand by kind
of seeing the numbers along the way
um and so i think
most of our reports have really been
designed around that um
we try to stay away from powerpoint
unless we're presenting something kind
of to the business side
we try to stay away from you know kind
of static outputs
but that being said you know with our
public reports we still come out with
pdfs that are gorgeous as well
um you know so i think there's there's
always that that level of you're never
probably going to get rid of it all
um and not everything can be interactive
but
um for the most part we've made most of
our outputs interactive which is is fun
you know for me and um and i think for
just the team as a whole
cool thank you
i'm scrolling through to make sure i
haven't missed any questions right now
but just want to open up the floor to
anybody um if you want to jump in and
ask anything live too
so um
in rachel's blurb about you before
um the meeting
said you're going to talk a little bit
about writing a job description for tidy
model engineers
i'd love to hear about it i hate writing
job descriptions and i'm writing some
right now
yeah no so i um
i think even with you know the way that
we approach um
titles or
what we're trying to look for it's it's
very much an experiment um
i think the main driving factor of that
was
we wanted something different that
really would relate to
our community um i think a lot of our
code is in our currently
and
we're we're constantly trying to find
ways to to kind of increase
um
i guess
that portion of
the business
um and so i think the main driving
factor of that role was just that um we
wanted someone that felt that they were
you know really talented with a specific
skill to apply and to be found
um and i think that that's
that's always something that you find
with data science right you
you post a data science role and that
could mean a billion things
and
that's what's always difficult about
data sciences
it covers so much that if you don't be
or if you you can't find a way as bad
english
if you can't find a way to to be really
specific about what you're looking for
um
you're you're probably just going to
attract a lot of people but not as many
people that
are focused on what you're focused on or
trying to accomplish
thanks zach
um is there a question that you would
like to ask to the audience
i didn't prepare you for that but
doing it on here i think that's um i
mean i just be interested like what
everyone does like what they enjoy you
know do you like coding do you not like
coding
um
all you know
anyone that wants to kind of introduce
themselves
on a personal level that would be really
cool
um
thank you for everyone that has asked
questions
um
i do have perhaps a related question but
i'm happy to introduce myself as well um
my name is seph
i enjoy long walks on the beach um since
i live in southern california um
but uh
i am i work for concert ai which is a
real world data company we worked in
basically cancer analytics to kind of
sum it up um
i i'm i'm curious because i've been a
part of this wonderful little meetup for
some time now um and we talk a lot about
like python and r and those are
generally our data science tools but i'm
curious and and this also could be for
you zac but for anybody else is what are
people's thoughts on limiting or
minimizing
use of both
both languages so let's say you minimize
python or you minimize r and just try to
consolidate the team on one
my personal opinion is that there's
technical debt that get that accrues as
you more languages you apply because
people obviously are comfortable in one
or the other but i'd love to hear what
other people's thoughts are on that
yeah so i i would be curious to hear
everyone's thoughts as well um and maybe
i'll just kind of quickly
um
i think it's it's a great question and
i'd agree that there's there's some
level of the more
technologies that you use or the more
um factors that you have
in what makes up you know a data science
team
um sometimes it could be hard but i also
you know have the sense that there's a
lot of value in both um or multiple
um and the more that you can find ways
to leverage it the better um but i think
it's just a great question so i i'd be
curious if if anyone wants to weigh in
as well
i see brian's i'll jump in
hi
i'm brian butler i manage a small data
science team at banking
um i am a fan of both
um in fact my junior data scientist
before he was started with me he was
mostly r and then he converted all the
python and i was doing all python but
i'm like
these are tools i i think about a
carpenter
how many nail guns they have how many
different saws do they have
it's the same thing like if i want to
bang out a quick analysis
i'm going to do it in r i can load the
data in i can write two lines of code
and i've got a gg plot that's
interactive and everything else and boom
i can solve that prob that question
pretty hard pretty easily
now at the same time as if i'm going to
do some serious natural language
processing or some
deep learning i'm going to switch gears
but the best part of it is what i like
doing is wrapping
python into our markdown
and doing presenting presenting through
these interactive
apps that you can use with
you know plotly and r and everything
else and then you wrap the base model
the python around it and
um
so i mean i i just think
you're not going to be skilled at every
tool you use but to think the more tools
you have
you'll be more effective because you'll
find the right one for the right job
i i think that's a great answer yeah
i see floors and rick are both unmuted
so i take that as as raising hands
maybe if i can jump down there
sure oh sorry
you go ahead floors
oh okay hello
my name is jeff florespot i'm from the
netherlands
actually first time i joined
this group but i think it's a great
question and actually the same applies
here for packages within rf because you
have so many packages you could restrict
yourself that to all kinds of packages
actually i just heard deeply i'm very
much fam
in front of data table to be honest but
i use them both and i see that both
deliver a lot of value
for us how we use it is is we we just
have a
good documentation how to use the
packages how to do your coding so we can
always take over work from from each
other i think the same applies therefore
using python
r but even julia or go if you add it to
your your markdown can be used as long
as you just um
document it well
i actually love that um
yeah i i think that
documentation and having an
understanding of how to use something is
is always something that that's worth
solving for um
and yeah i i really like that answer
because like i would love to go into an
r markdown and see like 20 different
languages and
find ways to to you know get value out
of all of them
that'd just be kind of fun um and so i i
really like that answer
yeah just just and one addition
for the whole documentation we use
actually the book down
i think it's also from uh
i never can pronounce his name to be
honest but uh
but it's amazing yeah so we have many of
those book downs where you just say well
like heavily accurate this is the the r
for data science is really great to do
your documentation for your whole team
and we publish it on a web server easier
to to search for all your style guides
for everything you have yeah that's
amazing
i like it i i would uh i would also um
echo the sentiment of uh using lots of
different tools i i'm just teaching a
data data science
full three-month uh boot camp kind of
course at the moment and we just wrapped
up a lot of what's going to be r and
we're going to go on to python next week
and i told the students right from the
outset that we're going to be using both
r and python and i tried to always
highlight why we're doing this in r like
we just all the statistics was an r
database was all in r that imagine was
all in our reporting was all in our and
we want to to python we'll be doing the
deep learning and machine learning and
things like that inside of python but
i'm not going to make them do statistics
in python
i don't think it's
i think it's worthwhile and i don't
think it's nice to do data margin in
python either so they have nice tools to
do that also in in r so i'll show them
some of it but i'm not going to they're
not going to be the same level and all
skills in both of them so i i like the
idea of use the tools that you got and
use the diversity that you got
instead of trying to do and us versus
them know you're gonna do everything in
this package or everything in this
language and everybody on that side is
wrong kind of uh sentiment i think is
something that i don't try and reflect
in my work and give to my students
either so i like that idea of kind of
using all the resources you have
available to you but when i talk to
people on the ground who are not just
training but actually working in
in
companies and consulting they say well
actually what really happens is that you
can use r but the i t department is not
going to support you in anything if use
python at least they'll take a look at
your scripts and they may give some
critique and try and help you understand
what's going wrong
so the support that they get from other
departments of the company
also determines what they're actually
going to use in the end so there's that
practical component
that is not as idealistic i think
no i i i think that that's that's
accurate um
i think at the end of the day that that
kind of gets back to
sometimes you have systems and that's
what you got to use even if there's a
better solution
um and so i think
that's always you know on the table or
part of it um
and i think
the only way that you can get kind of
people to convert or to see your side of
it is just to create something cool um i
think at least that's worked for me is
if you can show someone something cool
then it's it's kind of easier to say
yeah this is why i use this or
um
yeah and so i i guess like
that's the
it's always part of the game um and i
find that the more you can make it fun
or
interesting is always the easiest way
[Music]
thanks for all of that if everybody um
can i add context to this question yeah
is that okay i was gonna say thank you
for asking that question and seemed to
fire everyone up
yeah i know i should have asked it way
sooner i apologize um so the the and i
this is great so i don't disagree with
everybody i think that obviously all of
these tools have a place in
everything so well sometimes python
especially from a data engineering
perspective that's what people are using
for for ingestion for etl and so it's
really helpful to have that tool set and
generally you'll always have that tool
set and for r for its variety of
purposes
what's interesting is what i see from
like an industry perspective is that
there's also a component that technical
debt that you accrue when people are
using multiple languages is that there
are systems that need to support those
languages right so as rick pointed
sometimes it's python and that's what
they're supporting right sometimes it's
r sometimes it's both but when you have
more systems or languages you need to
support
there's more libraries there's more
whatever all of that plays a technical
debt on whatever the it system whatever
the platform system so generally you
don't want to have 20 languages you want
to limit it and so python r is fine
but there's also a technical debt
towards
expertise towards like if i'm if i only
know how to do it in sql and i only do
it in sql but another team is doing it
in python and another team is doing it
in our right you now have three
different ways that you're approaching
perhaps the same problem and people only
want to then deal with it in the
language that they're most familiar with
and so
from a broader perspective when you're
trying to scale
like it might be helpful to say look i
know you i know you know how to do it in
sql
but learning it in r or doing it in
python or whatever the choice would be
may have value for the company as it
scales because once that person leaves
or if they go on vacation or something
someone else can then pick it up and
then i think flores said documenting it
appropriately is is great and i 100
agree but i guess that's just the
context behind the question i'm not
trying to say that we should pick one
language or another but um i guess you
know
maybe if i can jump in on one quick
comment about that one of the things
that um i noticed we were writing the
book this past year the r in python for
modern data science and
we kind of almost had a hard time
finding nice use cases and i got some
examples from colleagues on twitter but
i realized that um you know we organized
the book in terms of you choose our
python dependent on
the type of data that you're working on
so if it's time series or unstructured
or
geospatial
there there's different um package
ecosystems that are well suited in each
of the languages and some of them are
better than others um like spacey is
fantastic for nlp i wouldn't necessarily
recommend although there's fantastic
things for nlp in r but space is really
kind of dominating that scene in um in
python and so we kind of said you know
think about the data structure um the
format of the data and the kind of
research problem that you you're dealing
with and then in the in the case study
we were kind of struggling to find a
really nice
flow uh like really nice example and we
got something really nice at the end i
think but
um it also occurred to me that one of
the reasons people end up using r python
that i see actually in reality with my
students that are working in research is
that they come into a laboratory and
they inherit a really terrible python
script that they cannot make heads or
tails out of it but the thing works and
there's no reason to reinvent the wheel
but they want to wrap it in r because
they can modify and do things with it
and expand it in r so instead of
learning and these are like crazy long
and super complicated scripts that i i
guarantee are much much easier in r but
they don't have the time to translate
that all to r so they stick with it and
then they just kind of have to deal with
a python script so i think sometimes
people use rn python not because
idealistic reasons not because they
don't want to but because they just
they're stuck with it like they they
have to use this python script or this r
script because somebody wrote it and
dumped on their shoulders 100 that's
accurate
yeah and
i um
i i was just gonna say you know i i
think it's a
it's a super interesting question
because it's it's
super applicable and at every
step of scale
that complexity or
that ease has to be kind of addressed
and so
it's it's almost like
we know that that's a topic we know that
people are going to use both
how do we really prepare for that or
address it and i think like our studio
probably has the best you know answer
for it but um where they're working on
it um one of the two but um you know i
think that it's
it's certainly possible that you're
building
without that full circle you know view
of it right like
um i know that there's a lot of people
developing python that i i don't know or
and probably vice versa
um
and so yeah it's it's hard to have kind
of a perfect solution for all of it but
i think it's an interesting question
one thing except that i found really
useful was that i have not restricted
languages on my teams and i'd see
certain people because of their
backgrounds they were either more
comfortable with one or the other
which was nice because they're um it
allowed for a lot of cross training but
then if people were unsure about a
problem there were even more ways
to try to come to an answer and
understanding
from a different approach whether it
python or r or different packages was
really good and thought provoking and
found more errors and got better answers
in the end
there is definitely
stress from having
more languages but
i think it's worth it
i like that yeah
and i think like
um
but the one thing that you just said was
you know there's almost some stress from
that and i think
um i think sep asked an earlier question
about you know how do people stay up to
date on languages and so i think that
that's that's one of the hard things as
well is like
if
if you're
constantly doing something
other than that how do you stay up to
date on what's going on or what's
important um but i love that there's
multiple ways to answer that and like it
offers more capabilities to do that
because that's that's really really
valuable and so i think that that's
awesome
uh
yeah all good conversation hi this is
bala i just want to add one thing said
so
right now if you restrict so both python
and r uh right now has so much maturity
and it's it's open source right a lot of
packages are being you know
contributed
for most of the standard use cases you
get packages which are wrapper around
the package which is done in python so
if there is a species package for nlp in
python there is a spacey r which is a
wrapper which basically runs the same
package in the r environment so if it is
a generic use case which you know
is being
used across multiple industries then you
really don't have that problem like oh
my developer have
it's much easier to migrate
because
the speed to market is what you as as a
data scientist you you would like as a
data team you would like to do so a
problem is given you want to solve it as
quicker as possible and if
if you're taking
or if you're adding red tape saying like
oh you can't use python or you can't use
r
you're naturally you know creating
blockhead so
i would say you should allow your team
to
explore in whichever language which is
comfortable for them but again
when they design just think about like
are there wrappers can i integrate you
know
whatever i've done so that it is
future proof just in case
yeah and to be clear i don't have any
restrictions i thought i thought it was
an interesting thought experiment
before everyone spears me and cancels me
or whatever
but uh but yes
thank you
i'd love for you to introduce your cat
as well over
i add one there thing and then i'm
completely i agree with you guys so and
then you need to
restrict it on your technical debt it's
difficult to keep everything up and
running just also for a decade there we
had a very specific use case where we
have actually needed to use python
there was a package in nr in 3.6 to
connect to the sap systems and to
extract data that one was not maintained
anymore by the maintainer from
australia sap is maintaining a python
package so now we are using a python
package and to get the stuff in our use
reticulat to get it in in in our and
manipulate it in oregon so now we have
to have them both but we have a very
strict distinction between the
functionality one is is importing the
data the other one is
building your model
and creating your uh visualizations
i like that it's really nice example you
can't you but you kind of got stuck with
it
and this is her name is excel actually
i'm kidding no her name is zoe her name
is zoe
bruno said
bring all the cats next week
well thank you all so much for
a lively discussion i just want to make
sure i didn't cut off any final
questions there
you know we're a little bit over but um
thank you so much for for joining today
and zach thanks so much for for sharing
your insights with the group
um just quick question for you zach if
people have follow-up questions where is
the best way to get in touch with you
linkedin or twitter what do you prefer
yeah no linkedin works great um and
thanks so much for for all the fun um i
had a lot of fun so uh thanks for
spending some time with me and and thank
you so much for organizing
thank you
appreciate it and i know i haven't been
saying this lately like who are the next
speakers and i don't mean to be keeping
it a secret um so same time same place
next week um we'll be joined by kobe
abayomi who's a face
vice president of data science at warner
music group as well so
thank you all for joining and hope to
see you next week too
you